now I think that that from the time I
was young to even now the idea that the
novel is is the big desirable beast and
mallory's to call it the Beast the
novelist I think I think that the great
writers more often than not our fiction
writers because the fiction writer has
the capacity to imagine to make up
things and the nonfiction writer
historian or the current events writer
or the the journalist the essayist are
restricted by having to be truthful and
also verifiably truthful but I believe
that you can counter this and not be
restrained by the form of nonfiction and
the limitations of nonfiction and having
to be truthful you can overcome this by
spending one more time I don't I'm not
myself very very prolific as a writer
I'm in my 75 years 77 years I've written
five long books I've had two short books
and four collections meaning I'm not a
lazy man I've written a lot but but the
amount of time I spend writing and
researching there are people who've
written three times as much as I have
but I take a lot of time because I want
to have a lot of time with my characters
because in my all the time I spent I get
to know my characters better i get to
know them inside themselves because of
the time i take and knowing them it's a
kind of courtship you've mentioned it's
a kind of relationship is very personal
I'm very personally engaged in my work
and my and the people i'm writing about
and as a result i can write with the
freedom since i know well what I'm
writing about who I'm writing about that
that borders very very closely upon
fiction writers who are making it up I'm
not making it up but I sound like I'm
making it up which is what I want to
achieve the lack of believability
initially on the part of the reader
wondering how does this guy know this
much as he make it up no I didn't make
it up I just knew it very very very well
and that took a lot of time though in
patients that word I use him curiosity
and patience capacity hang out and to
write about ordinary people as if they
were in the imagination of a fiction
writer extraordinary Willy Loman is a
great character a minor character but in
the hands and an imagination of the
great playwright Arthur Miller are in
willy loman is an international figure
played on the stages of the world death
of a salesman is around the world in
many languages performed every week
minor character but not minor when you
get a great play and a great writer like
Miller to write